humans are funny in that we tend to
learn by experiencing first what we
don't want before we don't want it
rather than saying this is what I choose
and putting our energy in that direction
it doesn't have to be that way we had to
have two Global Wars before we said no
more war we've had to have Holocaust
before we say no more Holocaust and
we've had to have these atrocities
before we say no more rather than
choosing to live and honoring all life
and all beliefs in a universal sense
there is an Awakening of human
consciousness that we've never seen
before and where that leads I think as
we embrace the fact that we are a global
family we may not always like one
another but I believe we truly love them
and I've seen evidence of that you may
not like the habits of one another every
day but when it comes down to life or
death we will lay our lives on the line
for one another and that's very unique
in a species so I think Consciousness
definitely there is an evolution in
Consciousness and that evolution is
unfolding it's not being shared in the
mainstream media you're probably not
going to see it on CNN or BBC but we all
know it's there need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation Hey Kevin
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Greg Braden and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two reprogram your beliefs
how do we start to reprogram some of our
beliefs well it's a good question and
you know the the techniques are beyond
what I can offer in in five or six
minutes here uh it begins with an
awareness allowing ourselves to have an
awareness and for me it begins with a
promise
it begins with a promise to ourselves to
be truthful to be honest to be factual
about who we are our relationship to our
own bodies
our relationship to other people our
relationship to the cosmos to God or
higher power our relationship to the
Earth our relationship to the past and
our relationship to the Future it's all
about relationships it begins with a
promise that we will not lie to
ourselves about who we are and when we
are faced with the immutable truths that
the new science is revealing we have no
choice
we actually we have we have two choices
we either discount and say we are not
going to accept what the science has
told us or when we Embrace those deep
truths then we have to relinquish
the beliefs that have supported the
false Narrative of the past and that is
a that's a choice that we all have to
make and I'll just be very honest again
what I'm saying to you flies in the face
of what I was taught in my formal
education through through University
through I was a corporate scientist in
the defense industry in the energy
industry and the information energy uh
system Cisco Systems is my last
corporate position
and everything I'm saying to you it
flies in the face of what I was taught
in those systems however
it is supported by the new discoveries
and when the new discoveries tell us
that they no longer support the old
story it's time for a new story and we
are living that time right now
you know what I I also know is it takes
a lot of work
to embrace a new story it's not easy to
change a belief system for anyone
when I was uh I think many of your
listeners probably know a little bit
about me if they're familiar with me I
I'm the product of very dysfunctional
family an alcoholic abusive alcoholic
family
um Survivor of childhood trauma
um my father the abuser left my family
when I was 10. and when he left my
mother handed me a book she she said to
me she says I am not equipped
to help you through what it is that
you're going to go through she goes uh
because I'm hurting too but she said I
think this book may help you and it was
written in 1929 it was a book by a man
it was a Sufi and his name was Khalil
gabran and the title of the book the
title of the book is called the prophet
yeah well each each chapter uh is is
very brief but it it invites us
into deep contemplation of some aspect
of our lives so when I was 10 years old
I read a chapter on work because I had
to lie about my age and go to work we
were very poor uh I had to to go to work
in a copper Factory is is where I ended
up
um because we needed the money and what
Khalil gabran told us about work has
been the Cornerstone of my life from
that moment to this moment it's on my
wall right now it's it's on a plaque in
front of my computer there it is right
there
and and it applies to the work that it
takes to change our belief system this
is why I'm bringing it up right now what
Khalil Gibran said is work is love made
visible work is love made visible do we
love ourselves enough
put the energy to put the work into
being honest truthful and factual with
ourselves so that we can become the best
version of ourselves possible ultimately
it boils down to something that simple
and it can be as complex as we choose to
make it but as a scientist I have to
tell you life is simple nature is simple
until we make it complex with symbols
and words and Mathematics so it all
comes down to life
do we love ourselves enough
to to put the energy into being honest
with ourselves about who we are and once
we do that and this is so interesting I
just have to tell you this I've I was
with a group of men I was in a manly a
very manly Workshop all males and and
some of the men said to me
I'll do this once but I'll never do it
again and don't you tell anybody
and I said that's beautiful and here's
the reason I didn't trick him I was very
honest I said here's the reason it's
because once you take that first step
and you open yourself to that truth you
cannot go back it's impossible to unsee
what you have seen it's impossible to
unknow what has been revealed you can
discount it but you will never annoy it
and if you're going to live an authentic
life of honesty and truthfulness then
you must Embrace what it is that you've
discovered about yourself and it just
goes on from there isn't that beautiful
rule number three use the power of
prayer I said you know when we see your
prayers on the outside what's happening
inside your body
so when when we think of Tibetan prayers
we think of the chant you know
and we think of the the mudras and the
mantras and the bells and the Bulls and
the Chimes and the incense we think of
all of that and so I said when we see
your PR all those things and we see your
prayers on the outside I was interested
what's happening inside and the man
through the translator he said to me you
have never seen our prayers because a
prayer cannot be seen he said what you
see are the things that we do
to create the feeling inside of our
bodies the feeling is the prayer
the feeling is the prayer now this
parallels what science is telling us we
we have ceremonies and rituals that are
meaningful to us
but this is what's so important what the
the Abbot said to me was the words are
not the prayer but in the modern world
we in in the west have been taught if we
say the right words at the right time
something is supposed to happen and when
it does not
sometimes we lose trust and we lose
faith but the words it's not the words
it's the feeling the very Human
Experience that has been discounted by
the patriarchy by the the male dominated
patriarchy Through the Ages the power of
human emotion is really where our
highest levels of Mastery and our
deepest levels of power women typically
are more attuned not always but
typically are more attuned to their
emotions because of their relationship
with children and childbirth their
relationship with nature and men as
Warriors it was believed that a man
could not be an effective Warrior if he
was empathizing with his enemy so his
emotions you know walk a mile in your
enemy's shoes that doesn't work on the
battlefield
so uh now I I personally have found that
is not true I I am a warrior you know
I've studied martial arts all of my life
and and I've studied uh human emotion
all of my life I'm a double cancerian
male
so cancerians are all about the power of
emotion
and I think emotion is our greatest tool
to to help us navigate with a different
kind of of warfare it doesn't have to be
hand-to-hand combat and in the emotional
uh Judo and the emotional kung fu
through the power of our emotions we
often can disarm
a potentially violent situation through
the understanding of our emotions and
that's a powerful form of warfare
so without anyone actually being hurt so
it's interesting the the you ask about
the soul the soul is
uh does it tune in does it choose well
the soul can be influenced what the
texts tell us is that there's this very
interesting relationship between the
soul and the body they cohabit uh and
the body is a vehicle they are united in
some respects but the soul is not
influenced by those emotions to the
degree that the body is so this is more
about bringing the vehicle the body
into an alignment to free the soul to
its deepest and truest levels of
expression rule number four never limit
yourself science is a way of knowing
and it's a relatively recent way of
knowing what we call the scientific
method it appeared about 300 years ago
during the time of Isaac Newton when he
formulated the laws of physics
uh is when we say the scientific method
began now other people argue and say you
know there were scientific approaches
that were done in the time of the Greeks
and the Romans and and it's true but it
was formalized and and structure was
given to the scientific method
science is designed to be constantly
updated it is not a static story and
this I think is where the mistake has
been made because we live in a world
right now there's a there's a battle
playing out multiple battles there's a
battle for our thoughts and you can see
that playing out mainstream media across
every nation that's not just America or
just Australia or just Europe or Africa
or China there's a battle for our
thoughts we all know that there's a
battle for our story
the way that we've been taught to think
about ourselves and the stakes have
never been higher because the way that
we think about ourselves determines the
policies that we embrace the laws that
we agree to live and abide under
those are all based upon our story
so all of a sudden you see the battle
for our story uh is front and center I
mean what could be more important than
that right now
so when we talk about that battle uh
there's a battle for who we are and the
way that we think about ourselves
Academia is trying to hang on to What's
called the standard model there's a
standard model for the creation of the
universe and the creation of humans
we call that the big bang and we call it
uh evolution
the science no longer supports that
story
and this is where science is stuck right
now so we we asked science to tell us
who we are
science is doing a really good job
and there are scientists that don't like
the answers
so there's an attempt being made now to
cherry pick the answers
and part of that is that science has
been hijacked by corporations they will
cherry pick the information that
supports their agenda and they'll leave
the rest behind
science has been hijacked by
corporations by politics this certainly
is true with the climate change agenda
and the climate change conversation by
religion uh science has been hijacked by
religion science has been hijacked by
Academia
and there are universities I I'm of the
age right now where I have colleagues
who have been teaching they're
professors at Big universities uh in
Europe and America they've been teaching
40 to 50 years is how long they've been
teaching and I asked them why can't you
share with your students the new
discoveries the DNA discoveries that
overturn
the story of evolution as we've come to
know it and what they say to me they
said Greg first of all they say if if I
were to teach the new discoveries it
would invalidate my 40 or 50-year career
as a professor and I said no it would
not it would actually show your students
how relevant science is because science
is made to be constantly updated with
new discoveries it's not static there
you cannot teach your students the story
you learned in the 1950s
because new discovery it's a technology
has given us the ability to look into
DNA in a way that we couldn't do in the
50s and 60s to look into the cosmos with
telescopes we couldn't do that in the
50s and 60s
so so the science in large part uh it's
very common right now science has been
hijacked corporations politics religion
and Academia so there is a battle going
on right now for our story for our
thoughts for our beliefs for our story
there's actually it goes even deeper and
I don't know how deep we can go into
this there's a battle for our very
humanness that's playing out and most
people don't even know about it there is
a thinking and an agenda that's being
perpetrated that says that humans are
frail weak powerless temporary
and that we need something outside of
our bodies computer chips to replace our
neurons chemicals in our blood wires
under our skin and to perpetuate our
species but what they fail to say
is that all of that external technology
mimics what we already do in the cells
of our body except our bodies do it
better
all of the the networking is based upon
neural networks that we we already do
and we do so much better in the interest
of time I'm beating around the bush I'm
just going to say it the average human
is about 50 trillion cells give or take
every one of those cells
0.07 volts of electrical potential is in
every one of those cells
small potential but you take 50 trillion
times that .07 and it's over 350
trillion volts of electrical potential
that's a lie every cell in the body
functions as a resistor as a transistor
as a capacitor
every cell in the body emits photons of
light it receives photons of light
that's information every cell in the
body on the external part of the cells
we have receptors that are like antenna
receiving information the genes in our
DNA pick up certain wavelengths of light
they are antenna receiving information
and we self
excuse me we self-regulate all of this
soft technology through our thoughts
feelings emotions beliefs breath and
focus and that is the core
of our most ancient and cherished
spiritual traditions and this is what
we're coming to terms with now because
there is a movement called the trans
human movement that is telling us that
our bodies need to be replaced with
machines here's the problem and then
I'll stop the problem with that is once
we begin to replace our soft technology
our natural neurons
and our the membranes that allow cell
potential ion potentials across the
cells or our crystalline structure of
our bones once we begin to replace that
in one generation
it's the use it or lose it analogy
pretty soon the Next Generation they
lose access to those neurons they lose
access to those capabilities
and the point and the whole point of the
work that I'm doing right now is I'm not
saying it's right wrong good or bad the
question is how much of ourselves do we
want to give away to technology and how
can we answer that until we know who we
are and that's the whole point we are
just beginning to understand what it
means to be human and the full extent of
what our extraordinary potentials are to
self-regulate our biology covid-19 has
brought this front and center with our
immune response that's another
conversation but I'm saying it's up for
us all right now so uh so all of this
comes into play when we begin talking
about the Battle for our story and the
role of science
we've got to keep science honest if
science is going to serve us and I think
that is a Monumental importance right
now also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five recognize
emotions men in the western culture have
been taught to deny their emotions to
stuff the emotions to simply not
acknowledge them I I was born and raised
used in a very conservative community in
in the Midwest of the United States
Northern Missouri and I come from a many
people know from a dysfunctional
alcoholic family I am a survivor of
childhood trauma based on that and in my
lifetime really my lifetime
as men we were taught that the trauma
was all in our mind is what we taught us
just the way that you think about things
and to Discount the hurt and the
emotions my father left my family when
when I was 10 and that through our
family into a traumatic uh experience of
sheer survival of low-income housing
government subsidized housing and me
leaving school early to to work factory
jobs in the afternoons because we we
needed the money and it was good I
learned a lot from that but in all of
those experiences I was always taught
and people just say to me suck it up
that was the term suck it up you are
you're a man and deal with it and I did
to the best of my ability but now what I
realize as an adult
is that it is the very emotion that
results from our betrayals from our
hurts from our fears that can either be
the source of our greatest strength or
the the source of what destroys us and
Jesus said this in the nag hamadi
Library he says if you bring forth that
which is within you it will save you If
you deny which that which is within you
it will destroy you and these are what
we are now finding about the emotions
now we know this is the truth of the
emotions that are either resolved and
reconciled so that the neuropeptides are
allowed to move freely or unresolved
that are stored in the tissues and
organs that we associate with our trauma
uh until we either resolve them or if
they are stored long enough unresolved
they will show up as inflammation as a
dysfunction to call our attention to the
organ so that we may resolve them and
when we we talk about the resolution of
emotion chemically
Candace pert the Harvard trained MD that
wrote the book molecules of emotion a
brilliant brilliant work
she actually defined what does it mean
to to heal and from a perspective of
these neuropeptides that result from
unresolved trauma it is simply allowing
them to flow freely in the body and
metabolize out of the body when they
metabolize they come out in breath urine
perspiration the way that we typically
excrete from the body so all we're
trying to do is to get these chemicals
freed and released and there are a
number of ways to do that oxygenating
the body through breath we'll do that
breath techniques uh and by redefining
giving a different significance to the
things that have hurt us in the past
this is where the heart comes in rule
number six discover your potential the
answer to the question how do we awaken
this potential uh first we have to
discover
what this potential is and this is where
the bulk of my life's journey has led
I'm a scientist I'm a degree to Earth
scientist a strong background in the
Life Sciences and what I found early on
Amber if if you ask someone to draw the
line where does science end in
spirituality and everyday life begin
the moment you draw that line you have
just fallen into the ancient trap that
keeps us stuck in the thinking uh and
the living that has prevented us from
embracing the deepest truths of our
existence the deepest truths of our
potential because what I understood came
to understand is as a scientist early in
in life back I was in school back in the
1950s 1960s early 1970s
and what I found was that everything I
was learning was placed into these boxes
there was a little box that was called
geology and a little box called
chemistry and another one physics and
you know mathematics and cosmology
nature doesn't know about those boxes
and neither does our lives so this is
why sometimes Academia seems to fail us
when we are are trying to solve the
problems of everyday life because we
have been taught that we are separate
from the world around us that we are
separate from ourselves
and this is one of those really
beautiful places where science
spirituality social policy and the
everyday life come together in in a
beautiful way
because the truth is that our ancestors
understood our relationship to ourselves
and to the world around us on a very
deep level they may not have been
scientists as we described them today
but they definitely understood that we
are not what we've been told and we are
so much more than we've ever imagined
and so that led me on on the journey to
some of the most isolated and remote and
pristine and beautiful and mystical and
magical places remaining on the earth
from the the highlands of central China
and Tibet and the monks and the nuns and
the abbots and the monasteries and Nepal
and India certainly and the Yucatan and
the shamans and the kurandaros and the
end of the Andes Mountains and the
alteplano Bolivia and all through the
desert Southwest and in the Aboriginal
traditions of the great land of
Australia and more and the bottom line
as different as these Traditions are
there is a through line that connects
them all and they all tell us that we
arrived on this Earth intact with
extraordinary potential where science
has asked us to believe that we
developed slowly gradually over a long
period of time now this is a very very
different way of thinking in the new
science this is where the science is
just it's so very cool we now have the
ability to do what used to be science
fiction we can abstract we can extract
the DNA from the fossilized remains of
ancient forms of life sounds like
Jurassic Park yeah and then resurrect
him even yeah they go well this is yeah
Jurassic Park with science fiction when
it was written and to the best of my
knowledge we are not resurrecting these
forms of life my Mike here but we now
have the ability we can actually pull
the DNA from the bone marrow of the
beings that we were taught we're our
ancestors that we descended from and
what we've discovered is that we did not
evolve slowly gradually over a long
period of time Neanderthal we didn't
descend her from Neanderthal that we
showed up we appeared on Earth two
hundred thousand years ago scientists
agree with that no problem with the date
the question is where do we come from
how did we get here and why is it that
we haven't changed in 200 000 years this
is not Darwin's idea of evolution so
what the DNA is telling us is that we
have the cranial capacity we've got the
the neural networks we've got the
physical structure that we arrived with
with all of the extraordinary
capabilities already intact they we were
equipped with capabilities of light
years beyond what we needed in the world
to survive 200 000 years ago and it
happened all of a sudden it did not
happen slowly gradually over this long
period of time rule number seven learn
to truly connect we have moved to the
the online streaming and the digital
models I think what we're beginning to
understand is that we are more than the
photons in the screen of a computer I'm
seeing your photons you're seeing mine
but we obviously are feeling a
connection and that connection is more
than just the the pluses and the minuses
on the screen I think this lockdown is
teaching us
that we are connected and that we can
feel the deep love of that connection
even when we are no longer able to meet
physically and and I I'm an optimist I
believe we will be meeting I'm also a
realist and realistically we're going
through uh a huge pivotal Monumental
shift in the way we think in the way we
live and when we come out of that shift
I think we will appreciate our
connection on an even deeper level rule
number eight let go of the past when we
talk about the hurts of life one of the
things that I learned very early is that
my hurt was directly linked
to my perception of the hurt
what I recognized is that the person
that I blamed for the hurt
did what they felt they needed to do in
their lives
and the only way it was possible for me
to hurt was to compare what happened in
that moment to another moment and think
about this
because
when the moment is all that there is and
there is no past that you're comparing
it to the moment feels very differently
so what I found was that my emotions
were very very closely linked with the
expectations uh in my attachment to my
past whether that past was an hour ago
or whether that passed was a year ago
mm-hmm
knowing this
I began to experiment with myself and
say what if what if now is all there is
how would I feel about
my partner breaking up with me or my
friend betraying me how would I feel
about that it doesn't change what
happens because we can't always change
what happens we are definitely empowered
to change the way we respond to what
happens and if you think about your life
when your heart is broken and when you
feel betrayed it typically is because
we are making a comparison between the
moment
and something in the past and the
question is what do we use as our frame
of reference what do we use as that
point of reference the same is true with
self-esteem when people say
uh you know I'd like to be in better
shape
or I'd like to be a better artist or I'd
like to be a better musician and I
understand the intent and I think it's
good to want to improve but we can only
be better this is really subtle that's
very very powerful we can only
think that we need to be better when we
are comparing what we are now to
something else
if we are not making that comparison all
we are is what we are in the moment and
if if we have truly done I'll speak to
our viewers if they have truly done what
they believe is is their best effort in
the moment then there cannot be anything
any better so I was asked recently uh
about my failures in life Greg what are
your greatest failures in life
and my answer was not what the
interviewer was expecting because from
my perspective I honestly believe I have
no failures in my life there are many
times when the outcome has not been what
I thought the outcome is going to be
but what I have chosen to do is when I
go forward with anything in life if I
say yes to an invitation if I say yes to
a commitment and I'm in a hundred
percent and I do all that I could
possibly do given those circumstances in
that moment now I could do nothing else
that's all I could do
and it's impossible for me to fail now
the outcome
I may have expectations of an outcome
that change but I've never thought of
that as a failure and I know it's subtle
it's a very different way of thinking
but it also has freed me from the
polarity of the success failure Paradigm
and allowed me to move forward with new
choices in my life and I continue I'm a
student I am a student of understanding
myself
my relationship to the world now I
continue to do these things rule number
nine study the universe one of the
Hallmarks of A Dysfunctional alcoholic
family is is tremendous criticism and uh
the the lack of a spiritual connection
to anything
so I was not raised in any particular
Faith uh my Explorations
as I began studying uh well as a child I
was studying ancient civilizations
ancient Technologies and books and the
moment I had the money uh to go to some
of these places
uh I began not only to experience the
archaeological legacies but the
spiritual traditions of the people so
whether I was with the Bedouins in Egypt
which was my first trip or it led me
into the the Andes Mountains of Southern
Peru and the the shamans and the
corondados and the mystics and into the
Yucatan of Mexico and the shamans and
the healers and then the monks and nuns
and Tibetan Nepal and India and all
through the American desert Southwest
and then in Australia into the
Aboriginal traditions and then the
Africa
what I found was that
our Global family
has memories and we have stories that
help us to embrace what we experience in
our lives hopefully in in a healthy way
and as different as they all are from
one another there are common threads and
that Common Thread is that we are the
product of an intentional act
rather than the result of random
mutations and random processes now as a
scientist I was taught that we are the
product that we live in a dead in Earth
Universe the product of the big bang
that we are the product of Lucky biology
and that competition conflict and
struggle is what has given us the power
to Prevail over other forms of life
that's my teaching as a geologist
what I have to say is that the
indigenous wisdom ran counter to that
and then that led me into the science
and I've got to tell you honest to God
the best science of the modern world has
overturned what I was taught when I was
in school the best science of the modern
world tells us that we are not the
product of evolution as we've been led
to believe
so I want to be very very clear with our
viewers I am a geologist I believe in
evolution it's a fact I've seen it in
the fossil record for many forms of life
plants animals insects that theory
breaks down when it comes to humans and
the new DNA science is what's really
causing the ripples in the scientific
Community because when we compare our
DNA today
we now have the ability to extract the
DNA
from the fossilized remains of beings
that we used to think we descended from
and when we do that and compare our DNA
to theirs we find that we did not
descend from those bigs that we appeared
on Earth 200
000 years ago scientists agree with the
date uh as what are called anatomically
modern humans and we haven't changed we
have not changed in 200 doubt physically
we have the same nervous system we have
the same body proportions same cranial
capacity I believe that we have evolved
consciously I think Consciousness
definitely has evolved but what it says
uh and when you really get in to the the
Deep science of the universe itself and
our relationship to the universe the
odds of us being the product of a random
process are just infinitesimal uh sir
Fred Hoyle the British astrophysicist
said the odds of our DNA forming from
random processes are the equivalent of a
tornado
moving through a junkyard and leaving a
fully assembled Boeing 747 in its wake
and we know that's not going to happen
so what the new science I did bottom
line the new science is telling us that
we live in the universe that is alive
and conscious it is not dead and inert
where we would expect to see life in
many forms in many ways
uh where everything is connected
and that we as physical beings
are the product of and I have to say
this as a scientist we are the product
of some form of intervention has
happened in the past to bring us to the
point that we are today and we'll number
10 the last home before some very
special bonus Clips is be an optimist
the vision that we have for ourselves
the vision that you see for potentially
what's emerging at this Crossroads what
does when you hear inspired Evolution
what does inspired evolution mean to you
well I would be very honest I'm an
optimist and I'm also a realist
and I am optimistic about our world and
our future in the long term
realistically we're going to go through
some turmoil to get to that to that
world because I'm just going to invite
our listeners just to consider this I'm
going to speak directly to them do you
know what a powerful being it takes to
live in the world that we are living in
right now
where we are seeing and experiencing the
collapse of everything that we have been
taught to trust and depend upon that was
built upon quicksand in the past
to to let that world go without having
the certainty of what comes next already
in place you know what a powerful being
that takes and that's precisely where we
are right now and all we have is
ourselves and ultimately that's all we
need because when we recognize
the power and the Mastery that's
available
within us that has been with us from the
moment we appeared on Earth two hundred
thousand years ago what it says we are
evolving and I believe we are evolving
in Consciousness our body may not have
changed but we are definitely evolving
in Consciousness and it means
it means I'm a musician as well as a
scientist so I'm going to use my
musician's poetry here it means that we
are the artists as well as the art
we are the artists designing
what we're about to live is the art of
our society of our communities that are
evolving right now so inspired evolution
is to me when I hear the word inspired
Evolution it says to me that I'm part of
the process and I am an architect of the
process rather than expering it as
something happening to me
I went to my first rock concert at
Jefferson Airplane the original
Jefferson Airplane
and what I saw Rob I'd never seen
anything like this I saw this group of
people on a stage influence the way that
in that in that venue was about 30 000
people so they influenced the way that
those 30 000 people were feeling in
their lives that group of people had the
ability to shift the emotion and the
feeling inside of the people that were
in that room and I recognized that but I
also recognize that when the concert was
over when we left we weren't outside
that feeling began to wane very quickly
and the people needed something outside
of themselves to to create that feeling
again in that time they were vinyl
records and cassette tapes they needed
to have
something to respond to for them to have
the experience well in the same year I
also had the opportunity to see another
out it was an event in a stadium with
about 70 000 seats and a speaker named
Billy Graham and it was a it was a
religious uh a religious oriented talk
and I have to say honestly I I wasn't
totally into everything that was being
said
but what I saw was a stadium of 70 000
people and they were being moved on a
deep level by the words
of one man on the pitcher's mound in
this outdoor stadium
uh it was at the uh Kansas City Athletic
Stadium the A's stadium in Kansas City
Missouri but here's the difference when
we left they did not need something
outside of themselves
to maintain that feeling because his
words had changed the way they felt
about themselves and their relationship
to the cosmos to God to one another to
the Earth to their communities and it
stayed with them because they were
changed in the presence of his words and
I I recognize both those at an early age
and I thought there's there's got to be
a way to combine
these two to the music and the sound I'm
still searching for that but the the
science the science gives us a reason to
think differently about ourselves and
it's based on honest truthful factual
information
uh if it's good science
and uh and from that we begin to think
of ourselves differently and we are
changed in the presence of new
understandings it all comes down to our
story what we're talking about is our
story doesn't have to be technical
uh but this our story
Our Lives literally are based upon our
story we solve our problems we choose
our relationships we heal our bodies we
choose our politics we build our society
all based upon the way we've been taught
to think about ourselves and what's
happening right now and I think we all
know this is our story is changing and
it there is a battle Rob there's a
battle for our story there's a battle
for our thoughts for our beliefs
there's a battle for our very humanness
that is unfolding and it's happening
right in front of us many people don't
recognize it because it is
compartmentalized but it is happening
right now on on the mainstream of the
world stage
so I go back to those experiences as as
a scientist today Through The Eyes of
what I now know and I know that the most
fundamental
act the most radical Act
uh of empowerment that any of us can
Embrace is to honor the Deep truth of
our story not the story necessarily that
we've been coerced into accepting or
believing not the story maybe that came
from our family or our religion or our
education uh you know Academia or our
political affiliations but the true
story of our relationship with ourselves
with the world around us with one
another with the past with the future
with the cosmos and if we believe uh in
in a higher power
and in the presence of that story we are
changed and that gives new significance
to what's unfolding in our lives it it's
a celebration that moves us from the
fear uh into the freedom of self-mastery
and the science is now telling us
literally the self-regulation of our own
biology what could be more powerful than
to be able to self-regulate up regulate
and down regulate genes to enhance your
immune response on demand to awaken
longevity enzymes on demand to create
resilience to a changing World On Demand
deep states of intuition and so much
more what could be more powerful than to
awaken to that possibility now in the
presence of a world that's changing
faster than we can document it in our
our textbook so it's a long answer to a
short question but the science for me I
recognize an early age that it was a
language that would help me personally
to understand my relationship to the
world that I was drawn to and that
comforted with me in in times of
extremes and I think that's true for all
of us today when the world begins to
change there's a fear
and in that fear people communities
societies governments Nations will try
to cling to an image and an idea
of the familiar world
of the past
yeah we can't go back to that world
because it doesn't exist that world is
gone
and this is where the suffering comes
from because we're trying to apply the
way we've been taught to deal with the
past
all right we're trying to apply that in
a new world but the new world doesn't
work like the world of the past so we
need new ways of thinking new ways of
living and it comes down to something
very simple two things
the most simple is about love the bottom
line do we love ourselves enough to live
our lives
in a way that gives our bodies what they
need to do what they know how to do
really well do we love ourselves enough
to live and to think in a way that
allows the best version of ourselves and
the best versions of our families and
communities to come forward and the
science tells us how to do that science
is telling us what we need to do to
self-regulate our immune system and
that's all the things we already know
diet exercise nutrition but there are
new new discoveries in terms of diet new
discoveries in terms of exercise and
nutrition I mean just for example when I
when I was
back in my 30s 40s and 50s
back in those days I was taught that
steady state exercise was the key so you
go out and you know you you you'd run a
half marathon or you run on the
treadmill for an hour or whatever it is
now we know
that that may not be the optimum form of
exercise for a lot of people what now uh
the human body is built for what's
called HIIT high intensity interval
training that's our biology is is based
upon that when we optimize our our
biology that I mean that's about hormone
balance it's about testosterone and men
and women estrogen and men and women uh
DHEA levels and all of those things
we know that we have a new class of stem
cells has just been discovered
we used to think that people lose stem
cells as they age and we now know that
you can be 100 years old and have access
to stem cells maybe not as easy but they
didn't disappear it's how you get to
them and nutrition and movement are keys
to to doing this so do we love ourselves
enough
to to give our bodies what they need to
do what they are made to do and when
when we begin to embrace that Mastery
all of a sudden change looks a lot less
scary yeah when we become the best
versions of ourselves we fear the outer
world that change less We Fear one
another less and perhaps most
importantly we fear our own power we are
extraordinarily powerful beings and
we're taught to Discount and deny that
power and in our powerlessness this is
what's happening in the world right now
there's a lot of hurt in the world for a
lot of reasons
we typically are not taught how they
heal that hurt
so what happened is the hurt needs to be
expressed and it's expressed as fear
and it's expressed as hate unresolved
hurt
becomes the the fear and the hate in the
world and we're seeing a world of hurt
where we begin to resolve the hurt that
we have within us
with a lot of reasons we've all we're
all experiencing loss we're mourning the
loss of a way of life every one of us
has lost something yeah we've lost
freedoms we've lost family members we've
lost jobs and careers if you don't know
how to heal that there's a lot of hurt
that comes with that and that hurt can
be expressed as fear for what the
unknown and as hate for those that
represent something other than what
we're familiar with so all of this is up
for us right now and the science is
giving us the tools
that allow us to transcend not just
survive but to transcend but to do it
we've got to let go of the old ways of
thinking and I think that's that's
probably the hardest thing
absolutely yeah we just covered a lot of
ground there didn't we that's amazing
wow thank you for saying all those
things thank you so much Greg
um sorry about that Amelia so well let
me ask you guys uh I don't know what
your ages are I'm closer to 70 than I am
to 60 right now and I I think you all
probably represent a very different
let's say I shaved yesterday
you know I to me you guys look ageless
you're my brothers you look ageless I
don't even think about it when I see you
but but I know that we're probably
talking about different Generations so
let me ask you for general program but
I'm just going to ask you how how does
your community see the the people that
you associate with in your community how
do they feel about what's happening in
the world
I think it's a lot of mixed emotions I
mean as you said there's a convergence
of Cycles so there's the cycle of the
climate for that in that area I think
our generation is extremely uh moving
forward a lot of their purpose a lot of
their uh unconscious and energies is
towards helping that there's also the
cycle of Innovative Technologies uh as
you said right and that's that's a
difficult one uh I I saw one of your
interviews talking about the neural link
with with Elon Musk that's one of those
things where
it's you never know what can happen with
that and it can be such a transformation
in in our Humanity so there's so much
that I mean to answer your question
there's uh there's a mixed emotions
mixed emotions yeah well you know and
this and this key
problems if we're not honest with
ourselves about the problems
and that I think is probably the biggest
hurdle because there are so many
competing agendas that are out there
right now so many competing agendas
climate is a huge I've been talking
about climate as a geologist I love to
talk about climate yeah because I was I
was studying this back in the 70s you
know when I was in the corporations the
idea of Love Means means different
things to to different people and that's
where the answer is yes you know we we
do need to have that and this is uh this
is why I say even before covet this was
happening we as a society and in some
cases as a planet as a global Society we
were already primed
for the fear are part of a very
dangerous game
and an ancient trap where we are taught
to hate and fear the things that prevent
uh the world from moving in One
Direction or another so we had the the
one percent the 99 percent and the
inequities and it taught people to hate
prosperity and and wealth and we have
men against women and we've got Muslims
against Christians and Jews against
Muslims and we've got blacks against
whites and Hispanics against whites and
Asians against whites and if you look
back if you step back and look it's
about every six months or so you know
there's a new division that is
introduced and it's supported in in the
mainstream and I'm not saying that there
aren't problems we got a lot of problems
but we've always been able to work those
problems out in our Societies in our
communities
but when people are influenced through
through media
and there is a lot of influence I
remember when I was a kid you know when
I went to that Jefferson Airplane
concert
back in the old days we had to let three
television stations
uh and they were actually news ABC CBS
and NBC and they were news stations and
the the broadcasters would as
objectively as they could they would
inform us as to what had happened
without
showing any uh any emotion they tried
not to or or showing any favoritism in
one way or another and I remember the
exception I remember when Walter
Cronkite I was in school I was in grade
school in Walter Cronkite announced the
assassination of John F Kennedy
and they let schools out and we all went
home and watched in horror the events
that were unfolding and first time I'd
seen a news broadcaster cry
he cried took off his glasses and he
held his hands in his eyes and he cried
which was very atypical
for a news broadcaster and we've come so
far from that we don't get news anymore
what we have are opinions
and the opinions are
uh are
for whatever reasons they are dividing
us as as a nation but it goes so deep
it's actually dividing us the very
fabric of our families it's tearing our
families apart I I know right now I have
friends who have I've never had any
children I've never been blessed with
children I think I'll be a good dad it
just never happened
uh but I have friends that are
and even at the dinner table with their
kids in high school and college who get
their information
from One Source in social media and the
parents are getting their information
from another source it's very very
different information and it clashes so
much at the dinner table some of them
cannot even complete the meal there's so
much hurt and so much anger and what
you're saying rob is historically it's a
very old game uh and it's being used now
because it works when you can keep
people a population divided there is no
it's it's hard to have common shared
values and common shared opinions
and this is what's happening to America
right now the very fabric of America is
the family the family unit the values uh
the history the culture is all under
attack and as we give in to that
division
what happens is our society becomes ripe
for a new way of thinking and a new way
of living to sweep in and it happens
before you know it so is it right wrong
good or bad I'm not going to say that
here I'm saying it's important that we
be aware and not fall into the dangerous
game that's dividing us from our friends
our families our communities our society
dividing us between nations
because at the end of the day we're just
people
and at the end of the day we all want to
we've heard this we all want the same
things for ourselves and for our
children
uh and we we have a pretty good idea of
what that is
so it is it's an awareness
and I think the most fundamental the
most radical act that any of us could do
is to do what you've done
turn off the external noise
that Distortion and think for ourselves
and you look around and ask yourself is
are these things really happening and if
they are make changes where changes need
to be made but do it from a place of
kindness
rather than from a place of hate
there's so much hurt in our world right
now
and we all are hurting
and we're all mourning loss every every
person on this planet has lost something
we've either lost loved ones and friends
I lost my mom to covet and uh right at
the end of the year
so we've all lost and and if people
haven't lost loved ones or friends we
have lost a way of life
so there's something we are all in
mourning whether we recognize it or not
and if we don't have the tools to
address that morning what happens is our
deep hurt is expressed as hate and
you're seeing that hate in the world
today and so this comes back
to the beginning of this conversation I
have people say something soon to me all
the time you know I don't have time to
understand myself because I'm trying to
put food in my table and feed my family
or I'm trying to do my best in school
and
and those I understand all of that
here's the thing we have been
conditioned to live in a world through a
way of thinking
that has served us in the past and we
have to say it served us because you and
I are here now so it worked well enough
to get us here
that way of thinking worked in the world
that the way it used to be the world
just changed and nobody told us that
there was no special on CNN you know or
or the Discovery Channel hey you know
the world changed I wish there was
so we've never been given the
opportunity to even mourn the passing of
the world that no longer exists so we're
trying to solve our problems and think
about ourselves the way we always have
in the world that changed and it doesn't
it doesn't fit it no longer fits so yes
we've got all these little things going
on but what I've found in my own life
personally if I can back up
and shift the paradigm and I'll tell you
what I mean by that but if I can shift
the Paradigm within which I'm seeing
everything all of a sudden all those
little things take on a whole new
meaning and they become a lot less
a lot less of a problem they come become
much easier the Paradigm is this we have
been conditioned
uh steeped in a story of who we are that
is based in separation competition and
conflict it began in 1859 people say to
me Greg 1859 you know it was over 100
years ago 150 years ago so what you know
it's a good question what difference
does that make it's a good question
here's the answer
the world we live in
the society the economic system the
corporations the medical model the way
that we're taught to provide for our
families the way that we are taught to
have the most intimate relationships
under the roof with the people that we
share our homes and even our bed with I
mean let's just get real we are taught
to interact with humans
based upon these ideas of competition
conflict and separation and even the
most spiritually minded people that say
I've transcended that when they are in
the heated discussion and somebody
pushes their buttons they go to that
lowest common denominator often of
competition comp they will lash out with
something really hurtful to defend
themselves it's not their fault it's
deeply ingrained in their subconscious
so as not if because it's already
happening as we back off and embrace the
new paradigm of cooperation and mutual
Aid that is huge it is a hugely
different way of thinking it means we
live in a world that likes us where
nature is not out to Snuff out every
good thing that happens to us it means
we don't have to be constantly Vigilant
in defending ourselves from the world
around us that is a hugely vastly
different way of thinking we have an
opportunity now
to begin with an entire generation of
young people
who now are steeped in the glamor of War
conflict and competition
to make that shift what would it look
like to have a world where we have an
entire generation of young people that
know that nature likes them and that we
live in the world of cooperation and
mutual Aid and connection we're about to
find out we don't have to wait long to
find out so for me simply backing up out
of the minutia momentarily
to look at the big picture and to make
that shift and once we make that shift
when you go back into the minutia
everything looks different to me when it
comes to an affirmation affirmations can
be powerful
um and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day some of those
thoughts are the words to the songs and
they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newburgh is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that creates stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift to the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work
for he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times that we have
lost our power and that we have no
ability to communicate with a greater
power with god with the forces around us
and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted from
the texts leaving us with a sense that
we are essentially powerless beings and
if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you're a victim you need a
savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality so for
me it's it's a uh it's good news it's a
beautiful message of Hope and
possibility
as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in um I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you you are becoming the
change so you're becoming the abundance
you're becoming uh the love the
Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
[Music]
well and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community uh as to whether or not I
would allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
uh their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path
and when we began as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and they'll also give me the reason to
test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't we covered a
lot of ground and for some people
they've heard it before for some people
it may be new
this we're talking about the scientific
way of interpreting and understanding
what already exists
and whether we're in a simulation or not
whether this is a virtual reality or not
we're here
and we're here learning something and I
think the best that we can do is to be
honest
truthful and factual with ourselves when
it comes to who we are and what our
potential is
and to to take that information to
become the best version of ourselves in
our lives and create the best world
possible
uh because we are in this world and
whatever it is that we're here to learn
um I think this is the path to the
learning I know so many people and you
probably do as well
who've had such painful lives Danica
that they will make the search
to understand who they are the diversion
in their lives and by diverting from the
reality of everyday life they miss life
itself and I I believe that life is here
I the beauty of this world this is such
we take it for granted the colors and
the sky and just water and the way Water
Works and music and our ability to
create these vibrations that move our
soul you know this is what life's all
about so I just want to invite everyone
I think it's good to entertain deeper
understandings and to use science as a
language but when it comes right down to
it it's about you and me in everyday
life
uh being the best the best people we can
be and and finding the joy that that
really makes our soul sing because I
think that's our Compass that's how we
know when we're on the right path every
one of us in our own lives we have to
develop what I call the the spiritual
anchor The Rock The Soul compass and it
has nothing to do with religion when I
say the spiritual anchor it's the
spiritual anchor is when we know who we
are in relationship to ourselves we know
who we are in relationship to the Earth
to one another to our past to our future
we know how we are empowered and what
our potential is and once you know that
we then can live Our Truth
in a world where there other people
support it or not when we depend on
other people for that support that's
where we give our power away and that's
where many of us come from
uh I'll just say to the young people
listening um I come from a very
difficult family background
dysfunctional alcoholic family full of
criticism uh instilling self-doubt uh in
in the young people I have a younger
brother
uh we came from the same family and we
had the same criticisms
um I didn't believe what my father told
me about my inability uh in life and my
younger brother he did believe it he
embraced much of it and it's so
interesting uh two different people the
same family same background interpreting
the information differently and I
attribute
my ability to uh to to let that
criticism roll off of me in my the
blessing I had very early on I knew who
I was and I understood
uh my place in this world at an early
age not everyone has that but I began
looking at an early age
you know it takes a lot of work
to
explore the potential within every one
of us what would it mean
to have a generation of young people
from the moment they begin in in school
in kindergarten from the moment they
begin to understand their relationship
to the world and the kids around them to
think in terms of cooperation working
together
in other words what can I offer
what can I give what can I share how can
I contribute which is very different
from what we're led to believe of what
can I get what's in it for me how do I
benefit
all right and this is we are all steeped
in this story so our economic model
that's struggling is based in the false
assumptions of competition and conflict
our corporate model is based in
everything everything so it's up for us
right now so this this right now we're
living this rare convergence of the
cycles that have changed the world as we
have known it and the new world that's
emerging the struggle and the suffering
comes from us trying to embrace that
world through the old thinking of false
assumptions of an obsolete science now
we've asked science to tell us who we
are and science has done a really good
job there are a lot of scientists that
don't like the answer yeah science has
been hijacked by corporations they
cherry pick the data by politics they
cherry pick the data climate change is a
perfect example of how that's happening
science has been hijacked by
corporations
by politics by religion and by Academia
for reasons of money and power and ego
and habit
and this is where we find ourselves now
and I believe that we are witnessing
the breakdown
of these old structures these old ways
of thinking because we're living in a
new world and and this is and then I'll
stop here it takes one generation one
generation has to be the generation
that lives
the old world
that is crumbling
and also lives the new world that's not
quite fully developed yet
so you're living in between these two
worlds and it takes a really
strong person
or a strong family or a strong Community
or a strong Nation or a strong planet to
live in this in-between time
without getting lost in the fear of the
unknown yeah this is where the new human
story comes in because the new science
is giving us the reasons not to fear we
are holistic beings living in a holistic
Universe part of all that is and that is
the fallacy for the way that we we try
to approach so many of our problems the
fallacy that we are somehow separate
from one another separate from our world
uh and Powerless victims of our
environment and I think one of the
things that's happening right now Danica
the if you know if you're going to have
a global pandemic it's good to have it
in the age of the internet because the
internet has allowed us to stay
connected and it's allowed us to access
information in ways that we we never
have in the past and part of that access
I think is the answer to to the question
that you just asked so I'm going to
begin the answer by simply saying
there's a battle that is unfolding in
our world right now on multiple levels
uh right in front of our eyes we all
know there's a battle for our thoughts
that's very obvious the media is
battling to inform and guide the way
that we think about ourselves and our
relationship to the world and how we
respond to the pandemic and the economy
and uh race and all the other things
that are up for us right now there's
that battle
but that battle is based upon a battle
for our beliefs and that battle is
playing out in Academia it's playing out
with what we teach our kids about who
they are and the way that they solve the
problems of the world that come to them
from from the time that they're very
young the battle for our beliefs uh
where did we come from are we an
accident of Lucky biology or is there
some intentionality underlying our
existence I mean that's a huge question
is the universe dead and unconscious and
inert or is the universe alive and
intelligent and connected uh that battle
is playing out
there's a battle for our bodies and I
think we're all getting that what does
it take to get healthy what's it take to
stay healthy what do we have to give our
our babies within moments of when they
emerge from the womb when they come into
this world we are conditioned to think
that they have to have something outside
of themselves in order to survive all
those battles are playing out but I want
to tell you they're all static they're
noise
and they're covering what I believe is
the deepest Battle of our time Danica
it's a battle for our very humanness our
very humanness is on the line right now
because For the First Time a recorded
human history we have the technology
that can steal our humanness from us in
ways that some people aren't even aware
of and other societies and cultures are
adopting very very quickly and I'm
talking about computer chips and planted
into the human brain and chemicals
injected into the body and wires under
the skin and the problem the problem
with this technology that's moving so
fast is that when we give our natural
humanness away when we give away our
biological potential to technology our
body begins to atrophy with respect to
those potentials so if we're planting
chips in our brain our neurons we've all
heard this before use it or lose it
biology you hear this all the time our
neurons begin to think they're not
needed anymore and so they stop
producing in one generation the Next
Generation they become uh an appendage
of something that used to be we're not
using them anymore and for the first
time in 5 000 years of recorded human
history the technology has the power to
Forever change our species and the
question and this I'm laying the
foundation to answer the question that
you asked the question is and I would
never
tell anyone or try to convince or
persuade anyone to or not to use the
technology but here's the key the key is
how much of ourselves do we want to give
away to the technology and lose forever
we can't answer that until we know who
we are and that brings us back to the
very first question that you asked and
it's I gotta tell you it's where the
scientific discoveries are coming so
fast and furious uh in these obscure
technical journals that very few people
get to see but they're based upon
peer-reviewed science and they're
writing a new human story and that new
human story is what the covid pandemic
is pushing us to understand there was a
very famous author and prophet in the
early in the 20th century his name is
Khalil gabran
uh and I began reading Khalil Gibran
when I was eight years old
and Khalil Gibran there is one sentence
that has been my soul Compass it has
been with me
I think of it every day I apply it in
every situation every relationship every
job every commitment what he said his
work is love made visible it takes a lot
of work to know who we are in this world
and to demonstrate for ourselves our
potential that is our love made visible
that is US loving ourselves in a way
that empowers us to be in this world in
a healthy a healthy way where we thrive
in the presence of all of the changes so
my invitation for any young people is
love yourself and your love made visible
is you taking the time to understand
your potential and who you really are
the good news is we have that
information now new discoveries new
science indigenous wisdom married
together I think we owe it to ourselves
to bring it all to bear in our lives
today
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Bruce Lipton
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there